my car so i do not have one
no
i'm sorry i'm sorry okay hold up i'm
gonna get this i should have did this
before
but i didn't
and here we are
wow
i think we're good i think we're
hey okay i usually have two phones on
this
not today i'm so tired
i've been doing this thing where i tape
my lips at night i know it sounds weird
um
but yeah i'll tape my lips at night so i
breathe out of my nose because it's not
good for you to breathe out of your
mouth
and
um
when you're sick it's tough i'm not even
gonna lie because you have to like train
your nose to like breathe out of it if
you're not used to it
so yeah that barely slept because i was
sick so i could barely breathe
anyways um i know
enough about my problem hi oh my gosh i
have five people in here already
it usually takes a little longer
um
but yeah so
last night for new year's i did not go
out
because
i don't know i do not get excited for
new year's anymore i did like when i was
younger and i would go out but i don't
go out i don't even drink anymore so
i don't even do anything nowadays
um
it's like hanging out with my mom
oh my gosh so funny story funny story i
got invited to
donovan
sharps like to do a show on donovan
sharp's channel um
like
when i get back to england because i'm
in the us now
and i'm going back to england in a week
um
by the way
the music reactions all my equipment's
in the uh uk so i don't have any of it
here so that's why it's like very
low quality like low budget um
low budget but
i was talking about
oh funny thing i was invited to do a
show
on donovan sharp's channel
and i saw his live the other day where
he was talking about how all the girls
are um the reason he like invited us on
is because all the girls were in
committed like long-term relationships
and i just broke up with my boyfriend
like a month ago
so i was like am i gonna get de-invited
what i wanna be rescinded
i don't know i don't care it's his
channel so i don't care if he does that
but i
i was just laughing when i was listening
to it because i was like oh
oh he hasn't heard
not not anymore
not anymore um anyways
what do i do in the gym i should do more
cardio i'm kind of chunky i'm like one
of the my body type is like strong
with a layer of fat over it because i
like to eat i'm sorry excuse me i have
gained all the weight not lost i'm so
mad all the way and i lost before i left
in the last couple months i gained back
over break in three weeks i'm like how
the hell
how the hell did i eat it that fast oh
my god
i keep i keep bitching about this
and i've been going to the gym too i'm
like my mom's cooking kills me man it
kills me
how many weights do i have um
i can squat i don't know what my one rep
is because i really hate maxing out
um
but i would say
if i had to guess i probably could
deadlift like 280 ish right now i
probably could squat like 250
if i had to guess based on like what i
do for like five
sets of five
cuz i do 210 i was doing 210 the other
day for five sets of five
pounds um and then i did
like 200 for squat
and usually i can go up
anyway i don't know
um
i did get your new year's message thank
you for that i always appreciate um
what's my favorite food
[Music]
probably cookie dough i don't know if
that counts real food sushi
but like for counting junk food and just
like
poor decisions in my life
yeah not not a proud moment but i really
like sugar it's a problem
that's my advice everyone has advice i
could go without alcohol
i could go with that i mean i would say
that's like i put it in my lifetime i've
had two vices i used to be a big drinker
in college
and
um
yeah i used to
i still i'm still addicted to sugar
those are my two vices but i got rid of
i stopped drinking heavy when i was
22
21 or 22. maybe 21 i think 21 was when i
stopped and
that was when i stopped drinking like
heavy but i would still drink a little
bit
like and then i kind of went from like
once a month to like once every two
weeks i don't know like once every two
weeks then to once a month then to like
a couple times a year and now i don't
drink at all so
that was like a slow so now now at one
point it was hard but now i can go
without alcohol
um
but sugar that is the one thing you see
my face it's broken out why
my mom's cooking
why does my mom do this to me
i said mom what are you making for
breakfast and she's like i'm making you
fat i'm like mom
what why why why do you do this to me
um anyways sorry i need to stop bitching
about that
i'll get it when i get back to england
i i do better
um okay
i'm trying to think what questions you
guys got in the chat
okay
oh i just got an okay also the pickup
video is done
i'm officially done editing it i'm sorry
i'm sorry it's taken me months
i'm sorry i can't help it i can't
what time are you i'm a scorpio i just
turned 25 in november
i'm getting closer and closer to the
danger zone every day
oh my gosh i watched the michaela
peterson rolo interview
in the beginning
i thought michaela was gonna win because
she was doing so much better
but
but
rollo came in he kicked ass i'm not even
gonna lie
you know what my least favorite part of
the interview was with rolo and michaela
peterson when
when michaela peterson was talking about
how
he made a comparison between her and
casey anthony and it bothers me because
as women like you
know what he was trying to say he was
not saying you killed your child he
wasn't and he said that so many times
but it's like what why is this come on
deaf ears you got your air pods in
michaela
don't get me wrong i think she's cool as
hell
i
think her channel is really good i think
she'll probably find another guy today
to be honest
actually against better judgment because
only because the average woman in this
country is like 160 pounds
and on top of that i think she has more
access to like
high quality men
than she ever has
because of like her social media stuff
so
i would say that is why
i would guess
she will actually find someone else but
we'll see i guess you know we're gonna
find out
um
i just i think the competition for girls
is so
weak you know
um
my favorite sports team i don't watch
sports but probably the bucks oddly
enough
because
i should be a bulls fan that's where i
grew up
a lot like ass but i don't know when i
lived in milwaukee when the bucks won
like were doing really well that was
really fun
and that's probably the most basketball
i've ever watched and i went to the nba
finals when they won
so
i don't know that's probably my
that's probably my favorite sports team
it's a good question though guys like
there's nine people in here get me to 10
likes
10 in the chat
double digits i want to go crazy
um
it's just kind of funny
to be honest
um
i'm so excited to do the up video i've
been
oh my gosh i spent so much time editing
it i hope it does well it probably won't
knowing my luck but
12 likes 12 you guys are
stop it you guys are too much too much
um
okay
it's so interesting another i was
listening to donovan's live and another
um
another
how i put it
um
observation i had and i was talking to
torsha about this too
it's funny how your upbringings and your
like experiences make you view the same
situation so differently there was so
many put in the super chat oh i'm 25 i
haven't seen this girl in 11 years
um
and she said she wants to like meet me
and
through my lens i was like
because he's 25 you're 11. so you
haven't seen her since you were
so
25 15
14 i'm like and he's like oh she friend
zoned you then i'm like we're gonna hold
a grudge from when you were 14
like
oh my gosh you know how ugly everyone
was at fortune you cannot but it's funny
because he was like oh she probably is a
kid now she probably looks old
and um
at my mom's house
oh i'm the your mom sorry i
but anyways it's funny because like my
upbringing i would not have that
conclusion i would probably say oh
well you probably got hotter you were
like 13. what do you
what do you mean um
have i watched the new andrew tate video
on the your mom's house podcast was
really funny no i haven't seen that um
my new year's resolution i really want
to get to
and this has been my new year's
resolution for a couple years so i
i feel kind of bad making it again
but i'm gonna do it every year until i
get it
that's my mindset i want to be 165
pounds um
yeah which is like 25 pounds lighter
than i am now i'd be cool with 170 too
i'd be cool with anything under 180 to
be honest
i'm tall i'm six foot though and i'm
strong
so
i'm not as big as you would think at
that weight but i'm bigger than i should
be so that's my number one my number two
is
i'd like to go to therapy for like six
months because
maybe three three to six just because
i don't know i was in a relationship for
a year so i try to like heal from that i
guess
um
and i
i want to get a hundred thousand youtube
subscribers this year that's my goal
yeah so one fitness one
youtube and one like mental i guess
so three
and i have a list i don't have it on me
so i can't list it but i have a list of
videos that i want to do this year and
like get done so
yeah that's probably my new year's
resolution
i'm not big into new year's resolutions
to be honest i just act i act um
do i drive in england no i do not have a
car i sold my car
i'm in my sister's car right now she's
probably gonna yell at me
um was it hard it would be hard to drive
on the other side of the road if i did
it but again i don't have a car so it's
confusing all the cars i've been in like
getting on the other side has very much
confused me
oh my gosh
but
i'm excited to go back i'm kind of sad
like i kind of get comfortable when i go
home because
being around my family and stuff and i'm
like i'll believe them but i'll be okay
um
do i drive stick no
you're jamming is paying off i see it no
i just gained like six pounds in the
past three weeks
you definitely don't see it because i've
gained weight you don't i it was paying
off before i came home for christmas
and then
nada
not paying off anymore my mom ruined it
it's my own fault my lack of
self-control ruined it but
also my mom's cooking
so i i appreciate it but
i just i'm i'm real on this channel i'm
honest you know
i'm gonna stay on the slide for five
more minutes oh my god
he looked look fit
i appreciate it but i'm telling you
i see myself in the mirror every day
um do i lift weights yeah i do my weight
numbers are going up i will say i'm
lifting like pretty heavy these days
but
yeah um
do more treadmill not enough that's
where i should do more
do more q a with your mom i know i
should um the paranormal captivity is
strong i don't know what that means
i don't know paranormal captivity
no activity that was my first r movie i
snuck it r rated movie i suck at do
um
how tall are you
six foot oh my god funniest thing
happened to me the other day i i do
frida fredo not for you alfredo
bang reactions right the music video guy
like the music guy and this guy is like
probably like the most hood guy you
could ever think of like he went to jail
for three years anyways so
um i i went
i was supposed to do a video with him
this summer like a reaction video and my
boyfriend at the time did not want me to
go because
he was like jealous or whatever he said
like the only reason he wanted me to
come was because i'm a girl he's trying
to hook up with me whatever
even though even though i invited this
boyfriend i invited him i said why don't
you come with me you can come anyways
um
so when i went so then this man goes to
jail
so i'm like
kind of sucks i was kind of mad because
then obviously didn't happen he gets out
of jail like a month ago and i'm
conveniently in florida which is where
he lives like this month
and
um
and um funniest thing happened like the
funniest thing so i i don't want to go
alone right this guy's been to prison
um
he
you know i don't know he's a guy i don't
know you know and it's normal with
content creators like a lot of times
your only option is to go to each
other's houses because where are you
going to go film a reaction video so
i'm thinking like i i don't want to die
right um i don't want to get murdered i
don't want to get killed those are off
the table i have too much to live for
too much
so what i did
was um
after he sent me like his address to
come over
um i bring my dad
and my little cousin
um to do the video so
i pull up in this i by the way
we have a
a very
rat like i don't know how to put put it
but this this van that we own is so
ratchet
it's so
ratchet like it looks like a drug dealer
man um you would be shocked with the
amount of success that my parents have
then they don't replace this fan i don't
i don't get it but it's the only man we
have in florida so we pull up into this
gated community right it's literally a
gated community and there's like drug
dealer looking ass van
and
um
and i um
so i
i pull up
in front of this man's like very nice
house right
and again most hood rapper with
that you've ever met in your life like
literally went to prison for three years
and i pull up like with me
and my father
and
my little cousin well not little he's
like 16. uh yeah and it was just a very
it was a very funny scene
because there was a point
yeah it was a very funny scene um
because it just is not
i don't know if you asked me in a
million years did i think i'd be at his
house with my father like
the answer would be no that was my last
choice of men to bring but at that point
being my boyfriend had broken up so
boyfriend can't come with me um my
my
um
who was it
my little brother was like out
out of town
so he couldn't come my older brother
just would rather die than go with me
he's like why on earth would you go
um
like why why on earth
would you want to go to that or
associate with someone like that and
like austin for youtube like very
clearly um no it was a reaction video to
his music so i filmed us like watching
his music together
um
yeah
so
it was my last option but i you know i'm
not about to go by myself i'm not trying
to get killed and it was funny because
when we left like my dad was like
that did not seem like the type he was
like a nice guy he didn't seem like he
tried to murder
i was like dad
i don't know
i don't know how this stuff works
um yeah no we got it i have to edit it
together because we just i filmed us so
i have to edit it like with the music if
that makes sense like i have to download
the videos from youtube edit them
together
um yeah but it was a very funny scene
very funny
did i get picked up on the pickup camp
boot camp absolutely not i had a
boyfriend at the time
i was not even about
to do anything did i film it no i filmed
the reaction and i filmed this like
before we got there but
um
yeah now he um
i felt weird it's kind of awkward
because on youtube like the moments that
i'd love to film i can't
i it's so awkward to pull up to
someone's house and like throw a camera
in their face the first time you're
meeting them
you don't know
you don't know
i tried to get in but apparently he was
doing a basketball game with little dirk
or like they play basketball and i was
trying so hard i was like let me on your
team
i will post up all of you please let me
in
he didn't go for it but
i had to shoot i had to literally shoot
my shot when it comes to the basketball
game
would i want to go to prison as a social
experiment
that sounds like something i would do
i'm going to be honest
if there was an opportunity where i
could do that and be safe because i am i
am a bit of a [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie to
you i'm a [ __ ] i get scared easy
so yeah pretty much
does that make sense
why do we break up um
i don't know
it's
it's a long story i don't really want to
go i'm not about it because he always
seems to find lives of me whenever i'm
talking about him like i don't know how
i think he has like spidey senses
because whenever i say his name on any
live
um it somehow he sees it
um
am i going to be on donovan sharp's new
woman panel show
um
um
okay this is i was talking about this
earlier so
i am right now right i said i'd do it he
said he did but i saw on his channel
that he's only having girls on that are
in like happy healthy successful
relationships and um
i was when i agreed to go on like i was
in a relationship
um
however i'm not in one anymore so i'm
like am i
am i getting kicked off
am i booted
yeah so
do i see the privilege girls have yeah
we have a lot of privilege tlc has a
show but you stay with the inmates
um oh yeah i mean you got do you know
people that can hook me up i think about
it
um happy new year what part of the uk do
you live in i live in east london i live
in the hood
yeah i definitely live in the hood
i mean i'm scared straight i don't know
what that is
so
um
but you could say it's a privilege but
also the reason
that he found me and i got to meet him
was because i reacted to his music
like none of that would have happened if
i didn't react to his music and like do
reactions of his
so is that privilege or is it that i
made the choice to do that
i don't know
is it it's a prison show
um
as long as i know i wouldn't die
as long as i know i want to die i'm sure
you have a lot of relationship with
experience you would think you would
think right
but i'm gonna be honest i had something
traumatized me in college
like traumatized i'm so traumatized i
mean it's my own fault
anyways um
because i was like obsessed with this
guy oh my gosh obsessed and i was with
him
and then
when
when i ended it because
it's a long story but basically before
that after that um
i didn't um
i didn't date or like do anything with a
guy for two years
so
like i i don't wanna i feel weird saying
this because this is the internet but
like i didn't have sex or like do
anything like that for two years
like i didn't know oral no nothing so
i like kind of took myself out of the
dating market when i was at
like my prime so to speak
um because i did that when i was 22 and
then i met my next boyfriend when i was
24. so
yeah
so i'm like am i am i going to be kicked
off the panel am i
am i gonna be
i don't know it's up to him if he still
wants to have me i'll go but i get it
it's his platform i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna
i just oh my gosh i was laughing
that's super celibate um
i don't know i feel weird i really don't
like the term celibate
because um
yeah
like i was
my sister's calling me
oh my gosh
um sorry guys my sister called me she
needs her car back i can't go to the gym
anymore
um i need tops oh no
um any top streaming shows you would
watch on disney amazon
it's funny okay funny thing i think that
i had my epiphany phase
at 22 i swear to god i think i have my
epiphany phase at 22.
because because i did all the things
that they do at like 20 oh my god no at
28 at 22.
um this is what i did
i
i stopped drinking right i got baptized
i did like
even though i grew up catholic but i
prefer the christian church so i was
like i'll just get baptized here but
um
like all the
i stopped like like i was celibate
for two years i'm like isn't that that's
like what you're supposed to do at 28 i
just did it at 22
maybe even 21 because i think
21 or 22 is like around around that
that i can't remember the exact like
date or whatever but
yeah did i did i have my epiphany phase
at 22
was i just was i early was i early to
the party
um
okay
is it better exposure to being kevin
samuel's refreshing fit uh
oh that's a good question um
i would say fresh and fit just because
it's like a lot
a longer
like show so you have more time to talk
where's the one is the pope guy i don't
know what that means
um a yandy from atlantic alphas oh maybe
i will that's a good idea
i don't know who the pope guy is pope
pope i don't know what that is
but
the
kevin samuels is for the older crowd
yeah i would actually agree like the
women that call into a show seem to be
older
oh weird though epiphany phase 22.
wild
so wild
i really did
oh my gosh
i really want to continue this live but
my sister just called me and needs her
car
i'm so mad i came all the way to the gym
for what for what
i smash mary kill
they gave me okay the only smash mary
kill where there's a guy that i was
actually attracted to
was tla he's so cute i don't care what
anyone says he's so cute
but everyone else like
i wasn't i'm not attracted to i mean
even rolo like
when i was given like him
i don't know the three i got it was like
rollo him
and it was it was a three i was like
rolo myron and
tim poole i'm like
i'm not
none of them to be honest
um
but
yeah tla
yeah he yeah um
uh
let's see
did i make
you guys are snitches though you guys
better not
you better not don't
don't snitch on me don't don't do that
this is a secret between me and the 15
people on here that's it
don't tell it's a secret
um
do you find dj khaled hot no
um rolo oh
rolo he's like a cool guy like i feel
like i picked him to marry because i
feel like i can get along with him like
i'm kind of nerdy i like researching
[ __ ] he already knows how to do the
youtube and like
he's kind of in the sector of youtube
i'm in so i was like
i feel like that could work
um
that's why i picked him when i was given
but those are my options
uh
why do you like to like um oh gosh
um
[Music]
okay hold up
okay i'm about to leave
you grab chat look does that mean
you
um left the catholic church i sort of
left the catholic church um i did
like i got baptized and i joined a
christian church because i prefer it but
i still agree with a lot of things in
the catholic church more than christian
so i don't know i'm like a weird
i don't think i'd have i have to do
another live stream to talk about my
thoughts on religion
um
but
i've always like been religious on some
level but i have a lot of like
things that confuse me about church
and when rolo talked about his like
thing on religion
yeah it like ruined a lot of things for
me but okay i really gotta go don't
don't tell him don't you guys better not
don't don't phones connected restaurant
don't try again don't snitch on me i
don't need to be snitched on
okay i have
i think he's a little old for me though
i don't i really prefer like
not that old to be honest
but
yeah like i don't that's not my
preference
but
yeah so that's what i'm saying like that
was the only one out of all the f mary
kills
that i like was like oh he's cute you
know
but out of all the other ones it was
like i guess
um
i don't know i think there's a comfort
in raising your kids in the same
religion that you were raised in
so i think a part of me like always saw
myself raising my kids catholic even
though i prefer the christian like
church like i feel more connected when i
go to a christian church
um but there's just like a part of you
that i don't know always wants to raise
your kids
in the same religion that you were
raised in
i don't
know don't know if that makes sense
but
it's like odd
but i don't know it's like
like i i just believe that your choices
are more like i don't
like religion is this weird thing where
they think no matter what you do like
you'll be forgiven and
i just don't think you can go to god and
be like sorry and none of the
the choices from your life
like i don't know it just doesn't seem
like right if that makes sense i don't
know
oddly enough
my thoughts on the manosphere um oh my
gosh that's such a broad i think it's
like a good place for
men
um i think like we have feminism you
guys have the manosphere
but
i don't know i think sometimes it goes
too far but
i don't know
okay i need to end this live because i'm
about to get on the highway and i don't
think i should live stream from the
highway so
um
i will talk to you guys next time
subscribe if you're on this live